we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's dive into the 4 6 9 area code our
next callers from the 4 6 9 area code
caller what's your name and where you're
calling from hey David I'm George I'm
calling from Dallas Texas cool what's on
your mind today I just wanted to say
thank you and thank you too Patrick Ford
for making the show I've been listening
since February
I just been really appreciative of your
stance on things and coverage of really
well and down on Earth topics you
provide a really good insight and you
don't really seem to fake it and you've
been doing really well I just want to
call and say thanks also have another
question regarding a Donald Trump and
impeachment so you think of him if if
his uh if Comey decides to I think the
FBI has cleared Comey to uh well I can
testify deviant Rumpel will let him you
can't Rumple let him testify well I
think will Trump let him I think that
there's no doubt Donald Trump doesn't
want Comey to testify I think it will be
hard if Trump has to watch Comey
testifying on TV it's going to be hard
for him not to be basically you know
going completely apoplectic on on
Twitter throughout the entire time but
there's there's a sense that I'm I think
Pat if Trump could exert sort of
behind-the-scenes diplomatic or
bureaucratic type of pressure against
Comey testifying he would do it I just
don't know that at this point there's
really much that can be done yeah I mean
this is in Congress's hands now he's
going to testify before the Senate
Intelligence Committee I don't think
that's within his realm of power to stop
them from having to call me testified
yeah and and again we we sort of have a
sense intuitively that the White House
might have delayed maybe Sally Yates
eventual testimony but ultimately
ultimately didn't happen in other words
ultimately the testimony happened the
delays did not succeed I expect call me
testify I hope that even though as
former FBI director he does have pretty
good security around them if you know
what I mean
they think all of all of trumps Trump's
team will plead the fifth I have no idea
I mean I really don't know that let's
cross that bridge when we come to it
let's wait for what James Comey Saturday
now I think James Comey testimony
congressional testimony is not exactly
the most exciting TV commis testimony is
going to be like the most well watched
testimony of its kind right I think it's
going to rank up there with Oliver
North's testimony and 1980s regarding
the iran-contra scandal I think you're
right I think you're right all right
thanks so much for the call thank you
very all right take care
that is it for phone calls today when we
take calls it is at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 we
will take a break and continue with the
Friday show after this